they're huge
i know it's like seeing a bus in the
water
and she looks at you with those big eyes
and she stares at you it feels beautiful
that's when you know that she's letting
you in
anwar patane
he's a photographer
and in 2015 he won the grand prize in
national geographic's traveler photo
contest for his photo whale whisperer
so we're talking about what it feels
like to come face to face with one of
the largest mammals on our planet
the first time
it was in roca partida we knew we were
going to see the whales because we were
hearing them
and when they're nearby your whole body
resonates it's so strong
oh i love the sound of the whales it's
it's as beautiful as seeing them
he's underwater and off in the distance
i saw the silhouette of the whale
big big surly that looks like a
submarine without features it's just
like a big object and as he got closer
things became clearer oh there's the eye
there's the theme
that's a big whale
it's a very big wheel
the most profound feeling he had was a
connection to the whale herself
she looks at you right into your eyes
yeah
and you feel the connection now there's
a mammal connection
you feel accepted
anwar has been diving for 17 years and
his photographs are more than just
pictures most of the photos i make i try
to share them because people that
doesn't dive and doesn't know the ocean
they might start to pay attention to the
ocean
and i like wales
it's a reminder
that we share the world with
very very wise and beautiful animals
down there
you